Oh
ah this has become a lot more difficult
than I thought it was gonna be
it was sup guys I'm cute I love tattoos
so I came over to Asia to get a two
thousand five million dollar turn to
okay so last year for my birthday I went
out to Thailand I was on the famous
Bangla Road partying it up and I just
dipped off on his side street it was
just a 2-shot we're doing big back
tattoos full arm tattoos everything you
want to see from a tattoo shop so I came
back to LA well I talked to my
supervising producer and he was like
yeah I'm not really feeling an idea but
my team lead was there so I had to talk
to her - she was like hell yeah so I got
to Thailand
headed over to the shop got right into
the consultation with Garrett and you
ran me through exactly what we were
gonna be doing getting tattoo and as a
way of expressing yourself my favorite
tattoo probably my back about 90 hours
was put into it so nine days more or
less and a whole lot of pain most
painful tattoo the head for sure it's
armpits that's up there got both of
those done the back would rank
I'm gonna hate to say this for you but
probably around the fourth worst with
you you first a console being today
we're gonna design go back and forth and
then on the next five days you'll be
going at it okay yeah you excited right
yeah yeah
after I'm talking to Gary I'm still
super high I'm laughing about we having
a good time but it's gonna be five days
it's gonna be like 40 hours of the
tattoos so like I'm excited because I'm
gonna have this piece of my back that I
always wanted but on the flip side I'm
like this butt hurt like period all
right so it's day one of the tattoo
sessions they told me it's gonna be five
days between five to eight hours every
day of tattoo so it's like I'm excited
he's trying to keep my energy up so I
don't wanna get in here and get nervous
and it hurts more than it actually
should walking up to the
nicely kind of nervous like I got a
tattoo in a while and uh last time I got
when it hurt really bad it was my chest
tattoo and uh hurt really bad
so he's talking so I'm in junior he's
gonna hit us from here because I'm not
gonna be able to
what is about to get us tell you so good
luck to you
how's that feel there's gonna be a long
couple of days of all places they
started right by my butt and right on
the spine too like it was literally the
worst possible spot so I read online at
the 10th to New York I was excited to be
there so my adrenaline was still pumping
but honestly I was should I was lost for
words
overall once that needle hit and it was
over I'm talking about one of the worst
feelings I ever had getting tattooed
immediately the first day was almost
completely full of white ink considering
that it was the worst part about the
whole tattoo I felt like day one I
really took it like a champ so boom like
that was it that's day one so it's day
two of tattoo sessions it's about 8:30
a.m. right now
big one wasn't like horrible definitely
had some moments with the shade and our
just super super super rough everybody's
telling me that as the days go on he's
gonna get worse and worse so I'm just
guessing
today then we know better than yesterday
we just started
[Music]
all right so day two we got right back
into it on a tattoo I can tell today was
a day about mostly detail I can tell
that we were taking it a little bit
slower today it was a longer session but
I can tell that he really wanted to take
his time make sure that the details were
in his tattoos
I was just listening to a lot of Wiz
Khalifa a lot of Nipsey Hussle just
motivational music just to get me going
through the tattoo I knew the act of the
day I would have seen progress so I was
kind of excited about that to have this
one portion of the back tattoo done so
my felt like day two was kind of like a
breeze I was really riding this amazing
tattoo hi like when everything's just
gone perfect like I barely put a tattoo
like everything's going great but little
did I know the next day would be one of
the most challenging days in my life
okay so day three this is where this is
when things turn I'm talking about I
almost died like I almost cried
this was the day where I thought that I
was not anybody finish this tattoo there
was a single needle white ink and
they're just getting at me it was just
bad I was super bad and my legs were
cramping like it was just someone's
going on this day that just could not
control
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
they three they think use camping up a
little bit i don't know how attend later
teddy so well so i'm just gonna hit down
to the store and i give him some waters
in bananas and hopefully he'll be sweet
when we get back so
you're doing something out here
[Music]
day three they just get worse and worse
are you even halfway finish it
I favor
[Music]
I don't know
[Music]
those really a sad day
so Stu a.m. morning after uh after day
three I'm in a lot of pain I'm having a
really hard time sleeping the majority
of my back is covered up so I have no
option but to sleep on my stomach we're
gonna try to get some more sleep before
the next session tomorrow because
there's only a few more hours until I
have to go back in he has the days the
one that just gets worse and worse so
he's just trying to fight through
hopefully just make it through tattoo
it's okay I was sad I almost cried
everybody was laughing at me because I
couldn't take it all my friends in his
shot was getting at me so the next day I
bounced back there nothing happened
nothing really happened it was just a
day everybody has a bad day okay oh man
so after a rough day three I really had
to step it up date for it and show the
guys that like I can handle this tattoo
like it's what I wanted I feel like I
should be able to stick it through and
get this tattoo done so I came back day
four and I was really in my zone I could
see a lot more to tattoo done now so it
just felt good again like I was back in
that zone of just being like even though
I'm going through this pain right now
like the final product is gonna be so
rewarding that it's okay something I
feel like I found during the tattoo is
at the right side of my body hurt a lot
more than the left side and I'm not sure
that's like some neurological like fact
there's something but it's just what I
figured out today's session
I really don't understand how excited I
am to say that ever since day two has
been really really really hard to make
it through these sessions so I'm excited
that it's the last session I'm excited
that spend very short session and I'm
also excited as detectors gonna be done
you know I mean so we can finally get to
see the fun brother and I see how great
of a tattoo it is yeah so for anybody
who's ever gotten a tattoo you know the
feeling of knowing that you're attached
was about to be down like no net turn
the final stretch so day five that's
really where my mind was at the entire
time
day five was just a breeze like it was
really nothing that could go wrong this
day and I'm just super happy and I'm
just super excited about the entire
experience like to be out in Asia to be
getting a tattooed expressing myself
with like some art that I thought was
dope and as I'm sitting here I'm also
thinking of the experience I had of his
tattoo shot but I came down and met all
these dope people like jr. and Tyrone
hey Garrett your steve-o and like Tong
the tattoo artist you're just a good
feeling in the tattoo shop that day you
know I mean like everybody was in good
spirits because like it was a project
for all of us everybody in the tattoo
shop was kind of invested and really
excited for the tattoo so it was just
dope to be at the final process of it
and to show everybody how it looked you
know an idea that you felt would be
great and I see other people respect
that idea was just really cooked if I'm
gonna be honest with you did hurt like I
it was okay like yeah it's like a bee
sting like really that's nice I could
keep it I'm done and I guess it's time
to show you guys a tattoo
[Music]
tattoos simply and there you guys been
asking the tattoo yeah let me know what
you think all right you ready
great all right guys what you think yeah
bro I'm good
so did you have help lubricating your
backer how'd you do that
[Music]
[Music]